schweinfurt in bayern eine lehre
innenstadt geschlossene geschäfte und
das bei einer niedrig incidents von nur
11,2 stand heute am sonntag
egal ob gastronomie oder textilhandel
alle leben weiterhin dicht bild spricht
mit denen die wie immer am meisten
betroffen sind den einzelhändlern und
unternehmern der stadt
es ist furchtbar muss ich sagen wir
würden alles dafür geben dass wir gerade
in den kleinen leben mit einzelnen
personen die wir dort reinholen ein
schönes einkaufserlebnis machen können
also man muss einfach mal an uns denken
man muss an die mitarbeiter denken diese
leute stehen in dem laden drin oder
sollten im laden stehen und wissen gar
nicht mehr von hinten ist das sind
manchmal mitarbeiterinnen die alleine
sind übrigen kurzarbeiter entgelt und
diese menschen werden ganz gesehen die
wirklich ängste haben man hat auf der
einen seite die große existenzängste bei
den unternehmerinnen unternehmer man hat
den frust man hat die die enttäuschung
den ärger auch bei den senioren wegen
der ganzen impftermine und weil das
alles nicht klappt man hat zunehmend
auch wirklich eine tiefe traurigkeit bei
den leuten zu hause weil sie eben
einfach ihre angehörigen nicht treffen
und das ganze verwandelt sich inzwischen
in so eine art in resignation aber auch
aber auch aber auch wir brauchen jetzt
eine klare perspektive durch die politik
die menschen sind nach 12 monaten corona
auch müde wir sind dünnhäutig wir wollen
jetzt das ist eine klare perspektive
gibt und das muss eine mischung sein ja
wir müssen beim impfen vorankommen wir
werden sehr viel über das testen jetzt
in den nächsten tagen auch reden da sind
wir viel zu spät da muss es jetzt klare
entscheidungen geben lasst uns doch mal
gucken in der politik in der politik
wohl gemerkt dass wir bei der nächsten
ministerpräsidenten runde auch was
anderes hinbekommen als einfach nur
weiter zu verschärfen und weiter zu
verlängern wir haben die erste chance
auf einen strategiewechsel beim impfen
verpasst und sind jetzt dabei auch die
zweite große chance durch die schnell
und selbsttests zu verstolpern
da geht es für mich nicht nur um die
schulen der ronzheimer sondern für mich
ist ein paket unter anderem mit
im test auch mit maske auch mit hygiene
konzept digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens dem schutz der
wirklich gefährdeten menschen das ist
für mich ein paket das über die schule
hinaus mehr gesellschaftliches
kulturelles leben ermöglichen kann
und für meinen geschmack konzentriert
sich die bundesregierung viel zu stark
auf die strategie wir bleiben zu hause
auf die fortsetzung des lockouts wir
hangeln uns von einem beschluss zum
nächsten
das muss jetzt beendet werden ich möchte
ihnen einmal zeigen was in österreich
passiert ist und dort die schulen wieder
aufzumachen denn dort hat man einfach
beherzt gesagt wir machen diese
testreihe das heißt gruppe test in
österreich oder auch lolli test den die
kinder dort selbst machen können das
funktioniert seit mehreren wochen und in
österreich sind so sehr sehr viele
positive ergebnisse herausgekommen und
gleichzeitig funktioniert der
schulbetrieb wieder viel viel besser
björn schittenhelm der im landkreis
böblingen etwas ähnliches wie österreich
geschafft hat zumindest auf lokaler
ebene
wenn sie sich das anschauen was
gesundheitsministerien sparender
versprochen hat nämlich diese
schnelltests für alle glauben sie das
funktioniert und wie steht deutschland
insgesamt da aus ihrer sicht da beim
impfen haben wir glaube ich eine
weltmeisterliche infrastruktur
geschaffen
da sind wir top aufgestellt wir haben
noch kein impfstoff und bei den
schnelltest ist es glaube ich genau
umgekehrt wir haben wir katastrophale
infrastruktur aber wir haben jede menge
schnelltest in deutschland wird dann im
internationalen vergleich aus ihrer
sicht verstellt angehende
entwicklungsland da sind wir ganz hinten
also auch europaweit andere länder waren
viel schneller in frankreich in italien
überall durften apotheken schon seit
wochen und monaten zum teil halbes jahr
lang testen